여러분들 건물을 사드리겠습니다 제가
찾아드리고 중계도 해드리고 관리도
해드리고
매각까지 도와드리겠습니다
[박수]
내년스 비산암입니다 저희가
강남빌딩 레이 프로젝트 2기를
시작하도록 하겠습니다 저희 1기가 한
3년 전에 저희가 모집을 했었어요
그때 당시에 한 200분 정도가
연락이 왔습니다
200분 중에 제가 한 번을 추첨해서
강남빌딩 매입 프로젝트를 진행했었고
이번에 좀 뭐 잔금 다 치르고 지금
공사하고 있거든요 그래서 지금쯤 좀
위기를 모집할 시점이 좀 된 거
같아서이 영상을 좀 찍게 됐습니다
그래서 일기 같은 경우에는 저희가
이제 강남에 50억 정도 되는 건물을
매입해 드렸고 지금 저희가 설계랑
공사까지 같이 맡아서 하고 있습니다
저희가 공사 완료되고 난 다음에
임대도 맞춰주고 나중에 엑시트 하는
것까지
영상에 다 담을 예정이고요 2기 같은
경우에도 저희가 처음에 매입부터 설계
공사 나중에 임대 맞춰주고
매각하는 과정을 다 영상으로 담을
예정입니다이 메인 프로젝트 같은
경우에는 저의 진짜 명예를 걸고
진행할 예정이고요 그 어느 때보다
제가
매입하는 마음으로
정말 좋은 매물을 찾아 드릴 거고
중개수수료 같은 경우에도 최저로 받을
예정입니다 그 다음에 설계라든지 공사
부분에서도 제가 신경을 좀 많이 쓸
예정이고 그리고 별도의 뭐 비용이
발생되거나
컨설팅 비용이 발생되거나 그런 건
전혀 없습니다
당첨자분이 해주셔야 될 거는 저희
유튜브에 나와 주셔야 돼요 그게
조건입니다
강남빌딩을 좀 매입할 예정이시거나
그러신다고 하시면 지금 저희가
설명란에 이메일 주소를 좀 남겨 드릴
거예요 그 이메일 주소에 좀
사연이라든지 이런 거를 좀 정리해서
보내 주시면 저희가 한 분을 선정해서
답장을 드리도록 하겠습니다이기도 많은
분들이 신청해주셔서 되게 멋진 성공
사례를 좀 만들고 싶습니다
빌딩 매입하는데 있어서 저는 제일
중요한게 전문가라고 생각을 하거든요
어떤 전문가를 만나느냐 어떤 좋은
사람들을 만나느냐에 따라서 투자
결과가 좀 많이 달라지 합니다 특히
빌딩 같은 경우엔 더 심합니다
든든한 조력자로 빌딩 투자하는 과정에
도움을 드리고자 합니다이 과정들은 다
어차피 영상에 남을 거여서 제가
열심히 할 수밖에 없어요
금액대는 한 50억대가 제일 이상적인
금액대일 것 같아요
강남 빌딩 중에 한 50억 정도 되는
빌딩을 매입할 예정이고 많게는 한
100억 정도 되는 건물까지
프로젝트를 진행할 예정이니까 지금 좀
준비가 되신 분이라면 언제든지
메일 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
강남빌딩을 매입해 주겠다라는이
프로젝트 2기 모집에 많은 관심
부탁드리면서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다